you see this in new employees all the
time company Chanel like Chanel they
have this rule that I absolutely love
that new senior executives are not
allowed to speak in meetings for the
first 90 days of their
employment they want you to shut up and
listen and the reason they do that is
because new employees so often feel they
have to talk in every meeting to prove
that you made the right choice to hire
them like we know you're smart we hired
you one of the things that we have to
remember and I think young people don't
realize is when someone gives you a shot
when they decide to put you on a stage
and give you a microphone or if they
give you a job you don't have to prove
yourself because you've already been
vetted